well
welcome to another episode of down the
middle it's
great to be with you here today uh i
would like to say
that this is part of valuetainment
economics but it's a misnomer
given who our guest is today
vikram mansharamani is with us
uh he's almost impossible to introduce
because that would take the whole hour
uh suffice it to say he's coming to us
uh from a much colder area than we are
up up on the east coast he's a lecturer
at harvard uh which has absolutely
nothing to do with his
with his background in education um
he has just written a great book think
for yourself
uh yeah i'm gonna throw something out
there i think in a world of social media
if there's one thing that 2020 has
taught us more than
anything else because so many americans
and people around the world have been
brainwashed
it is that it is critical to think for
yourself so i highly recommend
grabbing a copy um and with that you
know i have
one overarching burning question to
start with
and that is do you have multiple
personality disorder
uh i mean you you have a degree in
everything that we could put economics
finance
um and yet you're not a lecturer
in economics or finance or even
policy you're tucked into the
engineering department
how did that happen and just give us a
just a quick rundown again we don't have
the whole time
just to introduce you we're actually
going to have to get on your predictions
at some point
but how tell us the circuitous route
that landed you
where you are yeah thanks you know first
of all thanks for having me i'm thrilled
to be with you
um and you know it's a really
interesting story that you're starting
with here which is
uh really gets to the heart of how i
think i'm a little bit different than
other people and
my way of thinking which is i think of
myself as a generalist
and as a generalist i try to employ
skills and insights from multiple
disciplines
and as such all of my undergraduate
training all of my graduate
training all of my own personal research
crosses silos
and you know to get to the answer to
your question
i ultimately was being recruited to
teach at harvard i was teaching at yale
at the time
and they were looking for a home for me
and they said well look you've written a
book on finance maybe
economics well the economics department
said you don't have a phd in economics
my phd by the way is in the field of
innovation and entrepreneurship from mit
i studied with the with the economics
curriculum at mit which is
pretty legit in the grand scheme of
things but uh in any case um
so the government department wouldn't
take me because i don't have a phd in
political science the sociology
department wouldn't take me because i
don't have a phd in
sociology the policy school said you
don't have a phd in policy
and ultimately i found my way over to
the uh the
school of engineering at harvard and
they said wow you sort of think
like a dot connector you're sort of a
systems thinker uh we had a great
conversation
they said we'd love to have you and on
the way out the door before they
formalized the offer they said oh by the
way
uh vikram where did you get your phd
from and i said well you know i studied
over at mit
and they were like oh well that's fine
that's legit um and they never really
asked what i studied but you know
everything's got the reputation so it
was fine
that's that that is that is truly truly
fabulous
um so uh
bring us around to
what what caused you throughout your
career
to see as much of the world as you
as you saw was is that part of this
multi-disciplinary approach
you take uh and what why are you waiting
on antarctica
yeah so uh it's interesting to know i
think you're hinting at the fact that i
have in fact traveled a fair
amount in my life but it is actually
very consistent with the idea
that every single perspective
is limited every single perspective
is biased and every single perspective
is incomplete as a result i've always
felt
if you think probabilistically the more
the merrier
more perspectives better insight and
that comes geographically as well i mean
we all live in our little bubbles
whether it's the economics profession
bubble
whether it's the u.s uh you know
intellectual bubble whether it's an
american bubble whether it's a western
hemisphere bubble
or whether it's a you know sort of other
bubble but
i have found it very valuable to go
and firsthand experience those different
perspectives
and whether that's all over the african
continent or in you know
on a plantation in southeast asia i've
made it
there to look and see so that i can
adopt different perspectives myself
uh i think that's really critical so
before we jump into your predictions
which um
which i'm fascinated by and i'm i'm not
i'm not in a place yet where i feel like
i can do predictions
per se and a lot of it has to do with
the fact that i focus on monetary policy
finance and economics these things can
change if the stock market moves by five
percent
then all of a sudden they're you know
they they meet around the oval table in
the eccles building
and all policy changes so i'm kind of a
real-time person
but i do want to ask you a question
about your travels
and your education and whether you were
able to witness
globalization yeah like yeah
yeah no it's a very interesting question
the answer is yes i mean look
i have been going to india for family
reasons
since the mid-1970s uh i mean
you you very visibly saw it there uh i
mean i
watched how uh foreign influences made
their way there
uh my first trip to china was in 1992
90 so excuse me 93 and you know
i got a sense as to what was happening
there then
and i've obviously been back since uh
and so i've watched globalization
my first international trip not family
oriented
was i was i was really blessed and lucky
to to go to a private school on a
scholarship um
and one of my history teachers in high
school
decided in 1989 let's go check out
czechoslovakia
uh which it was called back then uh and
so we went to prague
um and i went to prague in high school
and
right as the soviet by the way there
were no mcdonald's there were no
sort of western influences and so i
watched globalization transparency
obviously going back to it 20 30 years
later you see a different world
so the answer is yes i have seen
globalization in different aspects
different parts of the world um you know
my first trip to china
the you know there was a mcdonald's in
beijing there was
i don't even know if there were
starbucks in china at that time
you didn't see a kentucky fried chicken
you never saw any of these western
brands
so globalization has happened in that
way of course and it's very visible
today
so let's let's jump into your first
prediction because
it's probably the subject that i write
the most about
uh the first time and it and it also has
to do with your global view because
uh i think inequality is something
that used to be restricted you would
think of inequality as
associated with a third world country um
or with a dictatorship
but but inequality in and of itself has
become
has gone global and not in a good way in
my view i think it has a lot to do with
central bankers
all kind of doing the same way uh all
kind of
pushing the same policies out that
widens the inequality divide
but you had your eye on inequality a
very long time ago
before it was such a buzzword sure yeah
no it's interesting it's a great topic
danielle
i uh i actually taught a class on
economic inequality back
geez this would have been years and
years ago i went and i taught it over in
singapore for the yale
nus uh college this was a new
residential college i set up over there
and i did it because
i really wanted to be controversial and
i wanted to show how inequality
in a place that was deemed so perfect in
in so many people's eyes
was actually rampant just not as
surfaced if you will
um and i really do believe that
inequality might in fact be
the single largest challenge facing
democratic capitalism
etc and and while many uh uh
many an individual will focus on
globalization as a
cause as an accelerant of inequality
pressures
i would suggest that technology has been
equally
uh at fault here um and it's not
just a globalization driven phenomenon
uh because
what we've fundamentally seen and i'm
glad we're asking this question you're
having this topic raised first not
at the end look let me be honest the
return
on capital has gone through the roof
while the return to labor has been
pinched
that results in an expanding inequality
that's continuing in compounding and by
the way
we all see it with the difference that's
happening right now because of
covid with the difference between main
street and wall street right
indices hitting all-time highs
unemployment's still elevated go talk to
any waitress any person who works at a
restaurant bar or travel sector a hotel
employee an airline executive they don't
feel so good
whereas wall street feels great um and
so there's there's a big deal there and
i agree central banks are a contributing
factor here
but the fact is return on capital has
gone through the roof while return on
labor's been pinched
that is a recipe by the way
for communism in fact the communist
manifesto the they in fact say
workers of the world unite overthrow
those in control
the marx angles reader points to from
each
according to their ability to each
according to their needs
by the way that is a wealth
redistribution tax
by the way senator uh from massachusetts
who
um you know uh works as a colleague at
the law school
or worked excuse me um ms warren
she suggested this i mean this is
actually all coming out of the
inequality problem
and so i think to help capitalism save
itself
from itself it becomes really important
to start installing better safety nets
we may in fact find
it is prudent to have higher minimum
wages
because ultimately you want your
employees
to be able to afford the very goods and
services you as a company produce
that if you pinch labor too much you're
pinching the ultimate source of your
demand
um and so um you know i think we need to
be more thoughtful about that
so you know you raise an issue of you
know there's a difference between
raising the minimum wage
and universal basic income yeah there's
a yawning gap between the two
and yet and yet here we sit at the
precipice
of continuing on
something that was introduced during the
cares act which
is effectively paying people to not work
and
if you want to look at the irony of it
one of my
one of my favorite examples in the world
right now is that china is
repairing improving or building 30
airports
so their fiscal stimulus puts people to
work
and there's a return on that fiscal
investment and here we and that's a
communist state
and here we are in the united states of
america talking about
implementing effectively a socialist
type of construct
universal basic income throwing money at
people
who don't necessarily need it not not
targeted
but very much a shotgun approach yeah
yeah look you're
there's not much i can add here other
than you're right uh look
fundamentally this idea of
supporting people in work
to get a sort of reasonable return on
labor expended
rather than the handout which diminishes
the incentive structures and all the
good benefits that capitalism brings
uh let me put it let me be clear i am a
free market
capitalist i love capital capitalism has
helped bring more people
out of poverty in the world than any
other force i can point to
this is a genuine genuinely good
way to organize however it's not without
its faults
and to protect itself from itself there
should be some
constraints one likes to hope there'd be
self-constraints right you hear of
companies leading companies in america
that are more long-term oriented
that are saying look we're going to pay
higher than normal minimum wages because
we want our people
to be able to go buy goods and services
that we produce you know
etc so i think you're right
not your question but relating to the
idea of fiscal
expenditures particularly deficit-driven
expenditures
debt by itself is never a problem what
you do with the debt
i think is a problem and how you choose
to allocate that borrowed money
if it's money that look if you and i go
if i go borrow some money from a bank
and have this spectacular you know party
and we just
burn it all tonight there's not much i'm
left to show with
i have nothing to show for that endeavor
tomorrow other than a good memory maybe
maybe right whereas if i instead took
all that money out
and i bought myself a bunch of lemons
and i put up a lemonade stand and i got
a marketing plan and i designed this
all-natural environmental gluten-free
lemonade
you know there may be some demand i
could generate a return on that borrowed
capital
and so what you do with borrowed capital
actually matters
and i think to your point handing it out
for consumption
is one use of capital that we might say
hey hold on a sec we're not clear that's
the best use of deployment
whereas investing borrowed capital that
could generate a return in
infrastructure in other ways
is a universally positive thing i would
imagine
um yes and if we had all the time in the
world we could talk about how germany
has produced the lowest youth
unemployment rate in europe and how
because it focuses on working with
companies to re
constantly reskill even existing
employees anyways
um if there's one thing that we saw
hit the boiling point uh
in 2020 into 2021
is the role that technology plays
in surveilling us
you know elon musk comes out and you
know
he says run to signal and of course the
day traders run to some other
stock and run it up from 60 cents to six
bucks this year
but how how do we live in america
and have a company like facebook say
the op the ability to opt out is going
away
on february the 8th prepare yourself i
mean how in the world does that work
one of your predictions for 2021 is that
this situation is hitting
a break point explain that yeah
so look daniel i think in fact i highly
recommend
this book uh by shashana zuboff who was
the first
uh tenured business school professor at
the harvard business school first female
uh tenured business school professor
shoshana zubov wrote a book called
the age of surveillance capitalism and
i have to tell you it is both
ridiculously insightful
and so deeply disturbing at the same
time
and it is in fact these big tech
companies
that have decided to hoover up all the
data that exists and connect it
so that their ultimate objective is to
manage
us uh to to extract away effectively
your autonomy
so that you may think that you're doing
things for your own doing but
they may in fact be guiding you like
they're like a mouse proverbially
through the maze to the cheese
so to say so what do i mean by that well
turns out google
will be reading your email on a device
and all the other things that
you use for gmail uh so that's fine
maybe google can read your email maybe
you say i have nothing to hide
uh they have your fitbit so they know by
the way your
heart rate is moving at a certain rate
when you're reading that email because
they have time stamps on this stuff
and then by the way they know you walked
into your house and the first thing you
did
was x because the nest device that they
own
is there and checks the monitors the
temperature and movement in that room
and so they know your pattern of
movement etc
now they also know that you checked your
email
that came from this person on an android
device there's two billion of those so
they have a data of where you are for
most of the time
they know not just because most android
devices have not just location they have
barometric pressure gauges
they can tell not just that you're at
the starbucks on the corner of 14th
and and third that you're on the 13th
floor of that building and there's a
family law office up there
so it's hey you were communicating with
people that you're not married to you
were at the starbucks with that other
person
then you went up to the family law
office they now surmise that there's a
high probability you're
considering a divorce here's your ad but
do-it-yourself divorce kit
um just a little too look i will
here in fact this is great evidence
right here on the video i've moved to a
dumb phone
because i don't like the monitoring and
by the way we haven't even gotten into
the
the metadata problem right so it's not
just
for instance that you use your phone to
tweet
it's that each tweet is tagged with i
don't know what the number is 50
70 pieces of metadata where were you
before what did you look at before what
was the email you read before what did
you do after which i p address was it
which app were you on before
uh what what you've been reading
thinking about et cetera beforehand
you know all of these things come into
play with each and every thing
and then they use big data and analytics
to say all right this
implies this about your behavior you're
thinking it what have you
uh so i think i think there's a there's
a reasonable call
to suggest we should restore our
autonomy by pushing back against this
and i agree with you it becomes
hard for individuals to do so which
means it is a
reasonable ground for regulatory
intervention because
uh you know there's no other way to
contain that perhaps
well you know i'm no big advocate for
big government but at some point
company becomes bigger than the
government that's right and and that
that's problematic
so you know we have become
as americans very inward looking
in 2020. there were so many things
happening whether you're talking about
the pandemic or the presidential
election
or the backlash against china did we
sort of miss something
in india what is your third talk
your third prediction because i think
something rather large
happened there in 2020 and where is this
headed because when you look at
demographics
at last check india's got more people in
china and a better demographic
composition of their population as well
yeah maybe maybe so i've had over the
last few years i've been doing these
predictions uh these five-year rolling
predictions since 2015.
um and in years past i said
india is going to be the world's fastest
growing large economy they're on fire
their demographic profile looks fabulous
i then went further and i said you know
what actually technology's coming forth
automated manufacturing the make in
india campaign will in fact attract
manufacturing but they're not going to
get jobs and india is going to be the
biggest disappointment there
is in the world because actually
this logic that economists of the world
have used for so long which is
there's this demographic dividend cheap
labor is useful
is broken that that actually is upside
down
we need to think of india as not having
a demographic dividend or a demographic
tailwind
but instead as a demographic headwind or
a noose around its neck
why do i mean what do i mean by that
well lots of young people means you
better
produce lots of jobs and we're not
talking about
you know so it's a development strategy
shift that needs to take place
here's what i mean china may have been
the last large economy
that took the farmer to the factory the
production went from
10 bushels of wheat to a thousand ipads
and those gains were then shared a
little bit back with that worker who
went and became a consumer producing a
consumer society
right that industrialization based
development strategy
i think is now broken particularly on
scale
and india needs a development strategy
at scale
and so the illiterate unskilled indian
farm
worker is now competing against a robot
that doesn't complain
that works around the clock that doesn't
have religious holidays or protests etc
and that when he makes a mistake the
engineer corrects it
and he doesn't make the same mistake
again ever
right and so i'm really nervous about
the long-term
prospects for the emergence of a large
indian middle class
i think it's a hope you know tim cook
said
china was great india is the next china
i have to laugh at that the average
indian the
gdp per capita is somewhere in the 2000s
but the iphones are costing what a
thousand bucks these days or almost
i mean half of an annual salary of an
average indian and you think you're
going to sell millions of these things
no will there be a market yes will it be
a big market yes
is it the next china no so that's number
one
now to the to the more recent prediction
i made which was india becomes
geopolitically important
i think this is really interesting uh
obviously i think so i'm biased
but uh india had an armed conflict with
china this this past year we
a lot of people didn't pay attention to
that you know in the in the border areas
where they have
disputes there were guns fired and
people
died this is between two nuclear armed
powers by the way
we might have remembered last year india
had similar conflicts with its
other neighbor pakistan which is also a
nuclear-armed power
and so this is really an interesting
part of the world and i would argue
potentially becoming as interesting as
any other part of the world from a
geopolitical and national strategy
perspective
um and i think the us will come to
conclude
that india can be a countervailing force
in that part of the world
against at least china right i mean sort
of we can
help have a influence in that region
um to combat the chinese influence
that's been growing
and by the way it can help also with the
pakistan relationship
but it has the potential to lead us very
much into conflict with
india's traditional patron saint which
is russia
and so that creates some complications
but it's something to watch
well i'll be keeping it on my radar and
i'm hoping for next year
you can tell us all how that india can
finally build out its
infrastructure i once tried to explain
to somebody
that the the multiple of highways in
china
was so big i needed an extra large
screen on my calculator and they're like
that's impossible there's so many people
there and i'm like no there really is
there are no highways
it's very funny you bring up
infrastructure in india daniel i uh
um i once on a panel i was giving in the
middle east um
they asked me oh well of course the make
in india campaign is going to be
fabulous it's going to change this story
right they're going to have all these
jobs and
creation i said that's fine you can make
in india but the infrastructure is
such that you won't be able to get it
out of india oh it's amazing
um let's shift gears here to uh
to subjects that's near and dear to me
i like to say that the biggest bubble
that we have seen in financial markets
is the confidence bubble
in central banks so
is there a bridge too far
will the fed ask for inflation
and oops get it yep assume that they can
impose yield curve control
because nothing has fought them since
the last time interest rates were going
up in 1981
so they've got a 40-year track record at
this point or so they
think is there a limit to central banks
and this is a question that i could have
asked you
in 15 16 17 18 19 and 20.
yeah yeah i think there is uh
i don't have any precision as to where
that limit lies
of course right so uh what i would say
is i believe that
the way you phrased it initially hits
the nail on the head perfectly which is
confidence in central banking and
my interpretation of an asset
such as gold is you can think of it as
the reciprocal of
that very confidence in central banking
and so if you think
the confidence in central banking is
likely to fall
well then your denominator's going down
which implies the
ratio should go up and it suggests to me
that what i call non-printable
currencies
uh have a very optimistic future they
have a nice
tailwind behind them and associated with
the tailwind that might
go with these non-printable currencies
such as bitcoin and gold and precious
etc um is in fact a underlying
losing of confidence in central banking
so those two
are sides of the same coin all right i
mean loss of face and
central loss of faith in central banking
as well as
um you know the faith in the
non-printable
side the non-politically manipulatable
currencies
is it feasible uh and gosh i mean i can
just
my twitter feed just went poof there's a
mushroom cloud over it
is it possible to distinguish between
gold and bitcoin
because the bitcoin addicts will tell
you that bitcoin is going to take out
gold and yet
in your one prediction you put the two
of them together yeah
there there wasn't a lot of uh precision
between those two i think they should
both benefit
um you know the argument that bitcoin is
in fact digital gold and in fact better
and sort of
infinitely divisible easily carried all
this stuff that is in fact
not the case with i mean look if i need
to run
out of a country and i'm worried and i
got to carry with me
i don't know let's say a couple million
bucks am i gonna
literally fill up the backpack with bars
and go that's one argument that okay
well i can just throw it on a device and
go i got it electronically
um the other argument is well gold will
be so expensive that you might not need
more than one backpack to bring the
entire wealth with you
right so there's there's an argument
that one's i'm on that side
yeah there's the flip side of the
argument
my point is these guys golden and
bitcoin may think of themselves as
competitors uh
and uh and and possibly uh quote-unquote
enemies but i would tell you
they are massively in this they're in
the same boat the tide has taken both of
them
one may do better than the other one may
ultimately
grab a bigger share but there are
devotees that will
always have a concern about the cyber
and the hacking risk and the
digitalization risk that will want that
tangible physical
in hand you know thing that for five
thousand plus years has been deemed a
currency
because of its scarcity because it
doesn't break down because it is
divisible because blah blah blah blah
blah
that i think there's a story for both
okay very diplomatic very very good
trying to be um so
um just i'm going in in chronological
order here
and i have to say uh i've never been one
i started off on wall street
and i it was a place where you could be
a woman a man black brown yellow
white in between it really it didn't
matter what you were it
the only thing that matters was what you
produced that was it so it was a great
place
to kind of neutralize all aspects of
diversity
um but you you see a you see a shift
you see a structural move and don't get
me wrong i mean women are
by far smarter than men so i get it uh
but why do you see this as being a
turning point if you will
yeah look i think the diversity motion
or movement if you will
has has gone um you know
has gotten escape velocity if you will
and that is
uh is likely to stay for some period of
time and really what i'm
suggesting in that next prediction is
that uh
we get mandated diversity at the board
level of corporations and that
activist investor or shareholder
services support groups
uh do that this has happened elsewhere
in the world you know the scandinavian
countries mandate certain gender
distributions on their boards
uh we'll see some more uh distributional
requirements if you will from an
ethnicity or sort of skin color
perspective
um so i think that's all coming um i
don't think it's a particularly
controversial statement to say it's
coming
uh we feel the pressures now um yeah so
i think that's
that's i i do see that coming so um
and i don't think it's a bad thing by
the way do you know i don't think it's a
bad thing because
again go back to where we started this
conversation more perspectives
better always these are different
perspectives
now i would i just always assumed that
people knew this
so now where i f where i have issues
look i am a minority i have
issues with this when people reduce
standards
and use a you know label as
a reason to put someone in a position
where you pass over someone who is more
qualified
that i have issues with but i do think
we have enough qualified women and
enough qualified minorities that that
shouldn't be a consideration
absolutely no i'm with you um
so i i've been saying for some time
don't get me wrong there is a symbiotic
relationship
between china and the united states
china doesn't have enough food
and we don't have enough technology but
there's this point of friction in
between called taiwan
and so walk us through your next
prediction because this is
enormous i i look at huawei's got
huawei's got
a third of all telecommunications
equipment on the planet is
in the hands of one company i mean you
could say that there is a
tangible national security threat
simply because of china's dominance in
the technology sphere but again there's
this thing in between
and the biggest semiconductor producer
in the world
happens to be right there in taiwan so
walk us through where you see this
headed
so i've written extensively and talked
extensively
danielle about the idea that this u.s
china
rivalry is not just a trade conflict
it's not just a tech race it's not just
a space race it's not just an
arm tree it's not just a currency war
this is
full spectrum great power rivalry
let's not call it anything else that's
what it is
um and so i think that's an important
context to think about
because when we get to this thing that
you
indicate wisely is between us this
little island
formosa or taiwan um
we have provided de facto security
guarantees
to protect them we also
have signed in the shanghai communique
that there is one china
based in beijing and so
in theory we don't recognize this entity
that we're providing support to
um in theory we're going to protect an
entity that is a
portion of another sovereign state and
the chinese view this
really uh as as quite insulting
right it's that uh you know i actually
met with uh some
some very senior chinese political
leaders uh
last year and the analogy used was
well wait vikram how would you feel if
we sold military equipment
and arms to california i said well
actually you don't understand i'd be
fine with that but i said
he said no no i mean like if it was part
of your country i was like yeah i
understand i'm joking because
the californians think differently than
the rest of us
but they view it as arming
one of their states effectively to be
independent
and foreign countries supporting that
you know especially given the context of
the
sort of foreign powers carving up china
in you know the 1800s through the early
1900s this is a
problematic history they believe the
great rejuvenation of the chinese
uh nation state has been coming together
they've reclaimed
uh macau they've reclaimed hong kong
they're bringing back
the sort of territory and here's this
one thorn that we
their rival in a great power sense
continues to support
i think it's the it's got the potential
to be a flashpoint
um and i don't know what that flashpoint
or how that flashpoint actually comes uh
into into relief so to say but
is it conceivable i think the chinese
were trying
very much to diplomatically
turn the political tide domestically
within taiwan
um i shouldn't even use that word that's
that's an assumption to call it
domestically
within taiwan um to turn the tide
would prefer that you use the term
domestically yes
well the idea being the chinese were
trying to get a local sentiment in favor
of reintegration diplomatically
peacefully etc uh i think after their
crackdowns on hong kong the
taiwanese election went the other
direction and that resulted in
a resetting of strategic thinking around
how to reintegrate this wayward province
back to the motherland and america
stands in the way
so i think it's a flashpoint i think
it's a real potential problem it's
something to watch
closely we'll see uh you know
this could be a real test of of us
military resolve in the asia pacific
well the stakes are pretty high if you
consider how you started answering the
question
with a clash of two superpowers that's
right
um okay so uh i
i need to know because um
well i was born the year after we
landed a man on the moon but uh what
good does getting back to the moon
do us i'm i'm just i'm curious and
then now i'm putting on my ignorant hat
so but just
walk me through why we need to go back
to the moon yeah
so a handful of reasons uh number one
the engineering science and basic
research support
to go to the moon and build out a moon
colony perhaps even
i think can be inspiring exciting
energizing
and um enabling of a whole
stem revitalization in the education
infrastructure so i think there's some
value there
oh that's definitely you you had me you
had me at revitalizing education you can
stop there that's so amazing
sorry continue but as a wayward
point so to say on your way to mars or
further
i do believe that the moon can prove
useful as a
refueling of whatever station you want
to call it so you know this is now
longer range thinking i think that's why
i put in the prediction that
they announced plans to build the colony
not that they built the colony by that
in the next five years um and so i think
that's coming
it may enable us to use some really cool
3d printing technology
and build structures on the moon etc so
there's some really interesting options
there
further there are materials on the moon
we know
the moon has helium-3 which can be a
fuel source for fusion um we know the
chinese have gone there with the idea of
maybe taking some of this stuff from
bringing it back home
okay so there may be some physical
commodity materials
uh logic to going to the moon as well
and so there's the scientific endeavor
there's the energizing and inspiring of
educational endeavor
uh there's the sort of future jumping
point logic
and what i would say as was the case
with a lot of our military innovations
through
and the military research through the
cold war there will be
a lot of unintended benefits right
whether it's
you know in the cold war communication
mechanisms generated something called
the internet
um you know we don't know what's gonna
come
we don't know what's gonna come or how
but the odds are in favor that there
will be spillover positive impacts
um now i know where to send
all four of my children who by the way
have been forced since they were five
years old to learn mandarin
they still don't quite they're starting
to understand they're starting to get it
as they age
um start it wasn't coveted as much
as it was the trade war
that started to re-jigger the way
we view the supply chain yeah now
i've been hearing rumblings from my
friends uh
who are our big china watchers that we
might see a second lunar new year in a
in a row effectively cancelled
yeah because the virus is not in muhan
province the virus
the virus is right outside beijing uh
and so
i mean again these these are just things
that i'm hearing but
i don't know that if you're ford or if
you're a major manufacturer
and you've been dealing with input
prices on a roller coaster
i cannot imagine another major
disruption in the global supply chain
uh i mean just but one example 24 of all
auto supplies come from china into the
united states
people don't realize how how integr
it's not like flipping a switch and
saying we're just going to move
everything to mexico or vietnam
it's it's not that easy but you see
this causing an evolution in the way
we we approach inventories yeah
yeah so a couple of things i'll say
there in terms of the dynamic
danielle first of all the global supply
chain logic
that accompanied globalization was
driven by a
lowest cost just-in-time logic
it was based on a handful of arbitrages
generally economic arbitrages that took
place
over the last 40 years right so you went
to where the labor was cheapest
by the way that logic doesn't matter as
much when you use technology
you went to where the taxes on value
added were cheapest
by the way in light of lower corporate
taxes in america that logic doesn't
matter as much
you went to where energy supplies were
consistent and you could have
some reasonable structure on your cost
side of things from an energy input
by the way north america now has pretty
stable resilient
regular supplies of energy at reasonable
costs so
that arbitrage went away you went to
where
uh you know transportation costs didn't
matter because there was this
frictionless world
well that's sort of we had some more
frictions put into play
so when you throw all of this into the
mix first it was the trade war you say
okay
this little widget that went into my
final product
sweet i thought it was six dollars wait
daniel you're telling me now after this
tariff it's gonna be 22
my business model just went out the
window i can't do that all right so all
right let me move it out of there for
that
oh wait now you're telling me hold on
that six dollar widget which i was
willing to pay 20
for because i had to change my business
model now you're telling me i can't even
get it
what because there's lockdowns okay
that's not acceptable now you're
ripping through my whole business so
that doesn't work now you're telling me
there's geostrategic reasons of my great
power
rival is going to potentially have
access to my supply chain and the
intellectual property and stuff that's
produced there
i don't like the sound of that okay now
let's rip it out of there oh by the way
then there's this esg
dynamic that says oh you want a smaller
carbon footprint for your supply chain
well a long supply chain has more carbon
being utilized in a shorter one
so okay that's another pressure point
anyway you can add these up there are
multiple pressure points that make me
believe the geography of manufacturing
is shifting and it's going to move
closer to end consumers
so producers and consumers which were
distance in space and time
are going to move closer and they're
going to move closer and so the idea of
just in time lowest cost supply chain
logic
is giving away to just in case resilient
supply chain logic
and that means part of resilience is
higher buffers
greater inventories to handle potential
disruptions
and i think it's best captured with just
in time
moving to just in case i like that
i like that a lot and it sounds like
it's probably promising for
mexico's and canada's economy well i
mean by extension
yeah i think it's a regionalization it's
not a
ending of globalization it's a
shortening of supply chains it's a
regionalization logic
um you know because labor still matters
it's just not as important
such that i'm willing to oversee or take
inordinate risks to take my supply chain
halfway around the world uh in the
middle of a uh
all these other dynamics yeah um so
so this next one i wish we could spend
the rest
of the time on because it is something
i've written on
so extensively and it's so important
so i'm going to ask you i'm going to
bait you has passive investing
ever truly been stress tested
because people tell me all the time
danielle no these bond etfs didn't blow
up look look
we haven't had global pandemic hit and
they're they're swimmingly fine their
fine passive is
try and test it it's fine so
my prior book uh boom bustology
the final chapter of the revised edition
was the passive investing bubble
is the next big bubble to go i don't
think it's been tested
uh it's a good idea that's been taken
too far
and if you think about it it's based on
a belief very simply that
prices are correct that markets are
efficient
that we should just take those prices
and minimize our research and other
expenditures
right be a price taker however what
we've found is as that market
share of passive has grown that that
price
taking logic has given way to price
making
and in fact flows will matter as much if
not more than fundamentals
and so when we have a huge tide of money
coming in it doesn't really matter
what kind of boat you're in you're
rising and when the money's going out it
doesn't matter
what kind of boat you're in you're
sinking and it's just as simple as that
fundamentally i could go further and say
this is a
this is genuinely creating a risk to the
price mechanism
that allocation of capital uses as the
fundamental guiding force
and so misallocated capital funded by
this devout religious belief that
passive is the right way to do things
is a recipe that has produced i think
a ticking time bomb that will go off
and i can't tell you what the catalyst
to make it go off i suggested in this
piece
that well maybe the retirement swings
from
inflows to outflows maybe that's one of
the catalysts
there's multiple potential catalysts for
uh the passive investing bubble to to
get pricked if you will
um the retirement uh acceleration is one
of them
well if you think about the news that we
were not paying attention
to in 2020 because everybody was focused
on the cares act
there was this little itty-bitty
one-line item that said
mandatory distribution is is put on hold
so i mean you've clearly been speaking
to somebody in the government
because because that whole demographic
impulse
was effectively neutralized with a law
so temporarily and at some point that
will that will give that can't hold
forever
right well at some point it's not
whether it's mandatory or not at some
point
i mean going into the great financial
crisis the baby boomers were headed into
their 60s
now they're heading into their 70s so
some of them genuinely are
going to want to retire they're not
going to say ah that's fine i'll stay in
the workforce another 10 years no big
deal
yep anyway no you're right i think
you're right this
is a big issue that people are not
paying enough attention to
so uh i'm curious
is we're completely shifting gears here
but it's your fault this is the way you
wait you're opening up the order fine
that's all right keep going even though
we'll probably end with 11 because i
just want to only talk about third
parties these days
anyways um can we rebuild
the virtual security
that's that i mean i i've never heard
anybody suggest this
literally yeah and maybe i'm just not
paying attention but i i feel like the
pendulum has already swung so far
that big brother is with us dot dot
forever
yeah so the concern here on this
particularly
particular matter uh danielle is the is
sort of the international
aspect of cyber risks and so
the hacking of the u.s systems some
federal systems
office of personnel management files you
know critical infrastructure files etc
these are really big and disturbing
hacks i mean these are
huge breakdowns that we need to be
petrified of
and that's one thing but some of the
cyber security experts i've talked to
both within the government and outside
of the government
have said that's not even the most
disturbing part the most disturbing part
is
we're not even aware if there's ongoing
monitoring that could be going on
on these systems indefinitely and one of
the only
truest purest ways to fix these systems
is to burn them down and rebuild them
right because
there may be effective trojan horse type
dynamics where
inside our systems today maybe they have
records of the
you know they're keeping it there's
ongoing monitoring and
logic taking place on personnel matters
confidential matters
who's spies what have you now that
becomes an ongoing risk rather than hey
we identified the risk we closed the
door
yeah it's not that clear the systems may
be permanently compromised i'm not
suggesting i know that's the case i'm
not suggesting
that it's not the case what i'm
suggesting is it's a very
real possibility and it will likely spur
calls for a digital rebuild right sort
of a rebuilding of digital
infrastructure
and that's possible yeah i think so
i mean i think it just takes like many
things it takes money you'll have to
rebuild a new system
get it test it etc then slowly migrate
over it takes time it takes money but
yes it's doable
between that and the moon we've really
really up education
um all right so here we go
uh third party
yeah full moose i mean if
i hate to use these words but if it's
not
now when would it ever be
yeah yeah look i i i have to
say i have always been someone who
prides himself on independent thinking
um and thinking for myself um
the logic of polarization
that has so deeply embedded itself in
american politics
and there's a lot of reasons we can talk
about why and how we got here i would
argue gerrymandering was part of the
situation i could argue there's a whole
bunch of reasons where the primary
became the biggest battle not the actual
general election
for causing people to go more left in
left-leaning districts or more right and
right leaning districts
resulting in this massive polarization
but that process has created
a totally empty middle ground and around
the centrist logic
which i think makes it really ripe for a
centrist slightly progressive leaning
long-term focused working in the
national
interest political party um
and i think there's a lot of appetite
for it
i think there'd be a lot of people
interested in in in supporting that
and i think you could get a whole new
revitalization of the talent that would
come into
politics right there are so many people
i know so many people i've talked to
really capable accomplished individuals
who we would want as americans
to be serving in office and they would
never consider it
given the dynamics of today they say
well if i ran as a democrat i have to go
party line everything or i'm going to be
outcast by them or if i ran as a
republican i'd have to be party like i
can't do that
and so there's no middle place for me to
think for myself
and i think there should be a party that
allows the conscience of the individual
to come into play
no crazy i mean politically speaking
i mean i i think the two most powerful
people in america
are joe manchin and steve king
i mean the independent and the moderate
democrat i mean it's it's amazing that
one person can say one thing in an
interview
and move the stock market yeah and yet
that's what we that that that's what
this has come down to yeah
by the way you can also imagine all
sorts of interesting coalitions where
you could
pull out the centrist instinct among
existing
existing individuals there that would
jump from existing parties over
and you'd get a huge support base formed
around the country of reasonable people
that just want to put this behind them
kind of dynamic so
um i think that's i think there's a real
possibility of a third party emerging
and have real success in the next five
years
yay hopefully they'll be calling you and
not me
because there's that mindset um yep
there you go
so every once in a while if i need
amusement i will
unmute my bubble vision so that i can
hear the latest commercial real estate
person say that
urbanization's going to come back and
come back strong and come back quick
i mean if you think about zero interest
rate policy and this isn't even just a
united states phenomena it's global
i mean what do you do in a zero interest
rate environment you build you build up
so we have these massive multi-family
high-rises we have more
offices we have more luxury hotels yeah
and yet you know again i turn off the
mute on bubble vision to hear them say
it's all going to come back and stronger
you would dispute that
i would you know so my view on this here
is that
covid was an accelerant uh
this was fuel on existing fires so to
say and
what i mean by that is we had pardoned
the medical pun
many pre-existing conditions and one of
the pre-existing conditions we had
was a greater utilization of existing
uh existing capacities right so
it was okay you have a home but
you know what you maybe are traveling
and so
why not monetize the empty home rather
than let people go to hotel and so we
got airbnb
uh sharing economy or you know what you
got this office space but
you know what danielle you travel all
the time hey you know what i'm coming to
dallas for a day i need an office
you might not even use your office fine
vikrant pay me 50 bucks leave it on the
counter i'll be good to go
i'll pay the cleaning paper fine great
so you get
co-working or you know hey we got all
these cars out there and you get uber or
lyft or what have you and so what i
think you've seen is that co-working
specifically was getting a real tailwind
and now the work from home phenomenon
is taking that a pre-existing condition
and accelerating it
and so you know i've talked to many
fortune 500
uh ceos and their boards one really
large company
has 30 million square feet of space
around the world
has said they're going to reduce their
real estate footprint by 25
in the next five years this is a fortune
500 company this is a multi
tens and tens of billions of dollars and
thousands of employees and
across hundreds of countries kind of
thing they're going to reduce their real
estate footprint
by 25 because they found that hey you
can actually work remotely hey we don't
need
everyone to go into the headquarters
every day we can have three days
one day of overlap we can have surge
capacity for the days where we have but
we don't need this much space
and you're right because of the over
building that's the supply side take the
demand side take the demand side down
the supply side's gone up
and what do you got you got a recipe for
some real headwinds
when it comes to real estate
at least in the in the office real
estate specifically i mean there may be
other dynamics that work in other well i
always when i speak of office
urban i always speak of urban
multi-family in the same sentence
because one was built to supply you know
to support the other
anyways um so uh
you think that there might be a solution
a different kind of a solution
to our carbon footprint climate change
yeah yeah so this is this is a great one
thank you for bringing it up dana
look i i spent a lot of time with
venture capitalists also and i spent a
lot of time with silicon valley startup
types
and some of the more thoughtful
individuals i know the real
pioneering innovative types i interacted
with some of them
uh back in grad school say what's the
problem
we've got solutions that's what we do we
as a technology community design
solutions so what's your problem and you
say well climate change is the problem
is it fine there's an engineering
solution here too
what's the problem too much carbon great
let's design something
synthetic biology or other mechanisms to
deal with that
or let's there's a whole field known as
geoengineering
which is starting to get more momentum
which is hey we can actually control
some of these climate change impacts so
if it's too much carbon
maybe there's i mean there's wacky ideas
vacuum cleaners that suck up carbon only
and pushed into outer space
there's synthetic biology that will chew
up the carbon
uh in the environment and produce
proteins that can be used for
for feed so you don't have to have the
whole agricultural uh
carbon footprint that goes into
producing protein
there's so many different dynamics at
work here uh it's a really
i like to believe optimistic uh
prediction that hey you know what
technology can have an impact here too
um and what we view as an existential
risk might just require a little more
creativity and a little more brain power
applied in a positive way
uh towards this end and that could move
the needle
uh and actually help us so this is
something we've
touched on a little bit and we were
talking about it in a different way i
was saying soybeans and
and semiconductors and the the
deficiencies between
china and the united states and that
inherent symbiosis
uh so where do you see this
leading and if there's a solution for
everything theoretically since you're in
the engineering school
why can't china just i mean this is this
actually is not part of your
prediction but why couldn't china just
eventually solve all of its problems
yeah so what i
think you're hinting at here is my
belief that the u.s china
decoupling the sort of great power
rivalry
uh and my analysis produces
deficiencies on one end and you know
deficiencies on the other side and so
this bifurcation
breaks up what was a functioning
uh system that that spread the goods to
where they were needed and
uh etc and what we find when we
when i do the spreadsheet there are some
very obvious
deficiencies that exist on the chinese
side and very obvious deficiencies that
exist on the
western or american-led side of that
ledger
the chinese as you've indicated have a
very big deficiency when it comes to
arable land productive agriculture
and sort of the needs to fulfill then
the sort of dietary
desires of a really large and rapidly
growing middle class with more consuming
power
right like that's just what we know that
um on the flip side
you know you hinted at some large
percentage of goods that we have coming
whether it's auto parts or what have you
from china i mean 97
i think it's 97 of antibiotics
are sourced from china that are consumed
in the united states 90 plus percent of
vitamin c
i mean we have major vulnerabilities we
know the rare earth vulnerabilities that
we've talked about that processing
capacity and capability etc
those are things that can be built
domestically here in the united states
or in the western ecosystem
uh it just takes time so i think that is
what's going on right now is that we're
seeing those vulnerabilities get
addressed
as best they can you know i guarantee
you that we are thinking about
our access to pharmaceutical ingredients
differently
post this pandemic than we did before
the pandemic
where pre-pandemic it was lowest cost
just in time
now we're thinking uh oh just in case
resilience
right uh and so that's coming forth but
i do think
rare earths and pharma are two that we
can imagine a lot of effort and focus on
um but on the chinese side you can
imagine the the sort of
uh the food specifically and there's
other vulnerabilities there as well
um you know they don't have any jet
engine capabilities and there's other
things but they will get there
and you know so to answer your question
can china eventually solve all these
things
uh is really a question about human
ingenuity i mean if the chinese are
gonna solve their things i think we're
gonna solve our things and
you know we'll have two ecosystems uh
it's really about the friction between
here and there
um so uh technology let's stay there for
for just a bit um my daughter
can take a picture of herself and
transform it into
all kinds of things look mom look what i
look like i'm like whoa
how'd you do that it's very simple just
do this this this and this
this has kind of gone mainstream
and it's become very broad and in a
world
in which we now know that wide swaths of
people can be brainwashed
the the ability to authenticate to make
anybody a public figure look like
they've been anywhere doing anything
with technology could theoretically
become
a political cesspool where you actually
have disruption i mean we've
look we don't even have to speak in
theory anymore we can we can speak
because it's in the rearview mirror
we've seen it
so what where where does this go
yeah so on this side of technology and
the in the use of deep fake technologies
um i think this is really problematic
and is going to require
uh so some rapid response and resilience
focused regulation
uh and what do i mean by that i mean i
think this is a genie that's
unfortunately already out of the bottle
i this genie's been let out now what we
need to do is have a rapid monitoring
and
and sort of regulatory regime to
authenticate so people can think for
themselves and say wait hold on a sec
did that person really say that that
person really say that i don't
i know it looks like them i know it
appears that they're authentic i know
it's definitely the face
everything looks my brain is telling me
it is that person saying this thing
but intellectually i'm having trouble
with what they're saying with what i
know they would say
and do i blindly believe that or do i
then authenticate or is there some seal
that's been put on that says authentic
or or is there some way to
check it so that we can evaluate so this
is a
really problematic area that i think is
is going to require some some some
serious thinking
but deep fake technologies that enable
videos that look authentic to convey
messages that may be
not authentic are going to be a basic
tool of international disinformation
campaigns
i think this in fact it may already be
right being utilized more than we
realize
um and so i i think this is worth
watching
unfortunately i don't have a an
optimistic answer or solution just yet
hopeful that people will come up with
one but uh right now it's it's
it's one of these you have to watch
topics
um so we're going to go way north here
and it's not every day that canada
and tensions are in the same sentence
you just can't
picture it and yet and yet
there is an 1800 kilometer
underwater mountain ridge that runs from
siberia towards greenland
yeah yeah where do you find this stuff
so i have been paying attention uh
danielle and i've actually written this
up over multiple predictions in prior
years
that the arctic could emerge as a
flashpoint geopolitically
so the arctic's one of my regions that i
pay attention to because others aren't
honestly that's why that's where i
believe truth begins on the fringes and
so
i i read the fringes um and you know
today's fringe turns into tomorrow's
truth and
i've been paying attention to the
geopolitical dynamics of the arctic
because of
global warming the northern passage the
possibility of fuels
and hydrocarbons being up there the
russians planting
a flag on the seabed of the north pole
and claiming it
as their land with the robot etc um
and so anyway there's a territorial
dispute
because of how the u.n convention of the
law of the sea works
over this underwater mountain ridge
which is really long and
canada claims it's theirs greenland
denmark claims it's theirs and the
russians claim it's theirs
and it actually has huge geopolitical
implications as to who
gets quote unquote sovereignty over this
um
and and anyway i think it's got the
potential to turn into a flashpoint
combine that with the fact that the
united states has been doing joint
military exercises with
uh a nato partner in norway uh in the
far arctic
uh or in the northern part of uh norway
that it happens to be also where
the russian fleet is pointed um
and so i think this is sort of again
creating some tensions that
um you know on a three to five year type
view
might in fact find their way to the
surface
bizarrely enough the arctic takes us to
uh the last subject
for the day and the one that that
hoovers up more of my twitter feed than
any
other subject and i i say the arctic
brings us to the subject because
when you think about when you think
about superpower status
uh he who rules the seas you've heard
that you've heard that phrase before
most people think that it is impossible
in the near term for the united states
to lose its global reserve currency
status
yeah and a lot of people
uh think that bitcoin can naturally
rise up and somehow displace the reserve
currency
you only have to dismiss 500 years of
history in order for that to happen
because at last check countries prefer
to have
that status as a way of dominating
the global economy so
what do you how do you envision the
evolution
or the loss of the dollar as a reserve
currency
status this is going to end up being the
last
the last part of our discussion sure
well we could talk about this forever
um look i think the us dollar
a reserve currency status exists
until it doesn't is it sounds like a
trite way to describe it but
it works right now because there really
aren't any alternatives there's no
viable alternative you thought maybe the
euro could rise to the ranks of that but
they fell apart they can't get their act
together the united states of europe is
not congealing
in fact it's disintegrating and so i
don't think that's got a really bright
future as a contender for a global
reserve currency
um you know do you go over to the yen
not really a declining demographic
profile
you know waning uh economic influence
doesn't really have a military okay um
the chinese yuan well i don't really
quite get the belief
that people have the authoritarian
regimes that have potentially
nationalistic instincts
uh that i'm gonna put my assets there
with the belief that rule of law that
they claim exists may not exist
could exist don't know if it exists but
i really needed to exist
to put my money there so there's no
alternative there really isn't
but with that said
the incentive structures are stronger
than they've
ever been for other countries that are
jealous
of the quote-unquote exorbitant
privilege that we have
to be able to print to be able to have
effectively unlimited demand for what we
offer the world
uh and and they're kind of jealous and
kind of angry about that and i think
they're going to work on trying to find
an alternative to the dollar
uh and by the way we've recognized it
we've fully weaponized the dollar well
bingo i was going to say the
weaponization of the dollar has also
contributed to that incentive structure
right uh you know using swift and all
these systems to sort of
uh you know attack and contain and
control
uh some of the
rogue or political
competitors i guess is the right word um
has the potential to really backfire in
the form of incentivizing
the emergence of an alternative now i
think it'll be really hard for an
alternative to emerge
i really do i don't think this is a
trivial undertaking
if it does lines up with an earlier
statement i think it'll probably need to
be some form of
hard currency backed by something
because people will have doubt
um and you know for years they'll test
whether or not that real
backing is in fact real so okay you're
gonna give me
x ounces of gold if i bring you a
whatever
um call the currency wherever you want
uh and people will test it like okay
here
where's the gold give me this or a
precious metal or platinum or whatever
it is just give it to me i want to see
it
and they're gonna test it for years
before they give it any real faith
um and they'll test it with small
dollars and it'll take time so we'll see
the alternatives emerge before they
actually emerge uh but don't
fool ourselves we shouldn't fool
ourselves i mean the the endeavor to
produce an alternative
uh is as strong as ever and like covid
you could see
inflation as being the accelerant so to
speak could be
that's right definitely um okay so i
we've just got a few seconds left so i i
i have to ask you
uh harvard yale next time they meet on
the pitch
what do you who do you root for i mean
i've got to know yeah
so i generally always sit with my
undergraduate affiliation which is
uh always daily there you go
that's right my my father was born and
raised in east haven i spent a lot of
time up in that part of the world so
i'm right there with you go yale perfect
great
well look uh we didn't get finished with
our discussion and the only thing that
that means is that we can come in
come together again happy to come back
looking forward to myself
thank you so much for your time today i
really really appreciate it
great thanks danielle enjoyed the
conversation thank you if you were as
fascinated as i was
with the diversity of knowledge that
vikram has i mean
truly amazing i want for you to do
yourself a favor
go back and listen to the discussion
that i had with leland miller
vikram and i spoke a lot about china and
china china's not is not a subject that
is going to go away
it's going to become much bigger a much
more prominent
focus in the coming years so go back
listen to the interview that i had with
leland and if you've not yet subscribed
to valuetainment economics go ahead
click on that subscribe button below
and i will see you next time for the
next episode of down the middle
thank you so much